chômage pour éviter les allocations trop
basse donc vous voyez madame la
sénatrice
j'ai la conviction que cette réforme
assure le meilleur équilibre possible
sur l'assurance-chômage dans la période
actuelle je remercie madame la ministre
vous avez déclaré il ya peu que vous
étiez une femme de gauche attac et à
attacher injustices sociales et bien
réformes que vous proposez n'est pas une
réforme de gauche et une réforme de
gauche s'est tiré les droits vers le
haut et ne pas aller tirer les abc vers
le bas c'est finalement avec ses
politiques que l'on frappe l'extrême
droite dans notre pays ce ne sera pas de
la responsabilité des erreurs est notre
invité politique ce matin c'est alexis
corbière bonjour bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec no mercy le mans series de
seine saint denis en détention pendant
20 minutes point d'interviews en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par sébastien qu
attendent les coûts républicain bonjour
sébastien bonjour
on commence avec la crise sanitaire
alexis corbière et jean castex qui est
donc attendu ce soir à 18 heures pour
annoncer de nouvelles mesures en tout
cas pour faire un point sur cette crise
sanitaire paris l'île de france ne
devrait pas être confinée le week-end
est ce que vous approuvez cette décision
il ya deux de critiques que j'ai envie
de porter mon premièrement sur le fond
faut imaginer comme ça ne cesse de du
rsa fait plus donnant maintenant on l'a
dit jean luc mélenchon l'a porté l'idée
on appelle ça la société du roulement
alors je sais pas si ça parle à ceux qui
nous écoutent mais d'imaginer une
organisation notamment dans l'accès à
certains établissements culturels ça a
été dit y compris des commerces en lien
avec l'année des professions il s'agit
pas de faire n'importe quoi le virus est
dangereux je ne sous estime pas le
danger
mais voilà il ya quelque chose qu'il y
avait une acceptation on va dire yan'an
de mesures très très fermé aujourd'hui
moi je trouve qu'il ya un degré
d'acceptation de consentement dans la
société
on ne peut pas être suspendu à comme ça
on ferme et c'est donc là il ya une
nouvelle organisation
il y compris sur les lorsqu'on va au
travail demandé à ce que les employeurs
mettent en place il est certainement le
fond d or et un peu différencié pour pas
se concentrer tous dans les transports
en commun sinon ça est absurde on dit
18h couvre-feu mais entre 17h30 et 18h
pour ceux qui prenaient transports en
commun on se concentre
c'est pas très pertinent etc etc donc
déjà il ya quelque chose qui n'est pas
fait et que nous regrettons nous avons
porté beaucoup de critiques deuxièmement
il ya une dimension
j'aime me dire démocratique que je si
j'ai envie de faire entendre du moins
une absence de démocratie
moi j'en ai assez alors et vous que on
est suspendu à ce que va annoncer le
gouvernement sans savoir quelles sont
les discussions exactement qui peuvent
avoir lieu et les différentes
alternatives comme député il ya quelques
jours monsieur le préfet m'a dit en
seine saint denis on va fermer ce
week-end qu'en fait maintenant on me dit
on va plus ferme est bon et ainsi de
suite
et là ce soir vous dites on attend que
monsieur castex l'oracle castex alors je
sous-estiment pas le fait fouillis les
premiers ministres mais pour qu'on peut
pas avoir une discussion y compris
ouverte là dessus à la fois aussi au
sénat à l'assemblée nationale avec
pourquoi pas des instances avec des
citoyens parce que le on dit qu'on est
en guerre mais j'ai des gens les
planches on l'a déjà dit j'ai déjà dit
la différence avec la guerre c'est que
l'ennemi le virus lui se fiche il peut
on peut on peut avoir une publicité de
nos débats à savoir des choix à faire et
ça aidera ski en consentement alors que
là on sait pas nier un conseil de
défense et une boîte noire qui prend des
décisions injustes et on en vienne à
attendre qu'est-ce qui nous est en
hausse et le préfet visiblement vous
avez entretenu le préfet qui vous a dit
que des sms que l'on reçoit nous avait
dit à ce qui était annoncé en début de
semaine par sms de l'udu parle de la
part du secrétariat du préfet de
seine-saint-denis c'est qu'ils allaient
avoir un confinement celui qui est
désormais j'ai cru comprendre qu'il
n'aura plus lieu
alors l armée vous approuvez vous
n'approuvez pas le fait qu'il peut être
moins non moi je suis pas pour le
confinement et continuer comme ça à
faire mes choses je vous ai dit que les
manuels mâcon a raison de ne pas confiné
paris oui mais je vous ai dit que moi ce
que je n'accepte pas c'est l'idée il ya
aujourd'hui on vision le consulat est ce
que comme tout ça et au jour le jour
moi je n'accepte pas les gens ils ont
besoin de planifier ce qui l'année - ya
beaucoup de professions de commerces de
restaurants de cafés feront là on est
devant des faillites est on ne mange
chômage et il faut que ce soit cela soit
repensé et je pense que les gens
accepteraient d'autant plus des
décisions s'il ya eu une discussion
qu'on y voit là il ya telle alternative
yat il ya celle là on choisit celle ci y
compris qu'on par exemple on est le
recul sur ce couvre-feu de 18h -
j'entends dire qu'il n'a actuellement
aucun effet vis-à-vis du ralentissement
de la circulation du virus ou très peu
et ses employés pour l'homme de fonds
fication panne offensive où nous dit que
le préfet vous avez parlé d'un
confinement ce week-end on a vu
l'opposition de beaucoup d'élus à ce
confinement est ce que ce n'est pas la
preuve que les élus ont été entendus ce
changement de pied bah je compte non
justement ils sont pas entendus moi je
n'ai aux jeunes eux comme député je ne
participe à aucune instance de
discussion visas avec les pouvoirs
publics
par contre on se décharge sur eux pour
certaines choses on veut leur faire
porter la responsabilité à vous de vous
débrouiller les élus etc
mais je veux dire bien souvent pardon
peut alors je vais parler là encore moi
ma circonscription la seine saint denis
deville que peut-être certains on nous
regarde connaissent montreuil bagnolet
très proche de paris on nous annonçait
au mois de janvier trois centres de
vaccination voix avoir lieu et en fait y
en a quand à l'hôpital andré grégoire et
maintenant on annonce prochainement la
l'ouverture d'un deuxième centre mais ça
devait avoir lieu déjà il ya un mois et
demi alors les gens s'inquiètent ya des
files d'attentes n'en plus finir pour se
faire vacciner
il ya un mois et demi le gouvernement
monsieur verdi faut se faire vacciner
vacciner les gens âgés ont dit ok ils
ont bien raison d'ailleurs et puis
maintenant inscription c'est super long
donc on a des problèmes et là encore on
a un gouvernement qui ne ne partage pas
l'information je dis pas que la
situation est simple mais qui avoue
navire est tout à gagner à créer à
l'assemblée nationale des lieux de
discussions et je ne vous pourquoi pas
des instants citoyenne de contrôle pour
que y ait un consentement à l'autorité à
des décisions difficiles qui soient plus
forts hélas lors actuellement et qui va
avoir lieu le 24 mars prochain un débat
entre le gouvernement et les
parlementaires à l'assemblée nationale
pour l'invention
ce ne sont pas des débats assez des
moments d'information auxquelles on a
quelques heures
le gouvernement vient nous dire une
chose après sa photo canon selon la
majorité c'est moi j'appelle pas ça un
débat ou alors si on appelle ça un débat
c'est un avachissement de la démocratie
qui était donc voilà je dis attention là
on en est un à une situation de tension
dans la société et après le problème
c'est qu'il n'ya pas assez de vaccins
après je répète ya pas une planification
très clair nous on a fait des
propositions dans l'es11 proposition
pourquoi pas cette idée de sociétés de
roulement pour ouvrir des centres
culturels
cet après midi à midi place de la
république avec le milieu de la culture
pour interpeller madame la ministre
il faut ré ouvrir maintenant alors bien
sûr avec des jauges avec la sécurité
justement emmanuel lacroix a piloté hier
une réunion interministérielle pour
évoquer la question de la réouverture
des bars des restaurants des sites
culturels et notamment la création d'un
pass sanitaire est ce que vous y êtes
favorable à non mais je suis pour pas
compte qu'on puissent vacciner largement
si on fait le pass sanitaires alors qu'à
l'heure actuelle vous avez
des files d'attentes d'un mois et demi
avant de se faire vacciner je comprends
pas la pertinence des choses après
qu'ils aient des réouvertures de lieux
avec des mesures drastiques
effectivement sanitaire c'est pas
forcément liés à la vaccination
alors ces dons c'est pourquoi dans l'eau
c'est pour conditionner l'accès à
certains sites qui réouvrira mais qui
est des contrôles qu'ils aient lieu que
la profession effectivement s'engage à
ce qu'il n'y ait pas didier des jauges
extrêmement rigoureuse et c'est moi ce
dont je me méfie c'est qu'on conditionne
l'accès à certains endroits alors qu'on
crée pas les moyens que tout le monde
puisse bénéficier en l'occurrence fois
c'est une vaccination ou qu'il ya
véritablement des ddd système de traçage
plus important donc je me méfie tout ça
mais voyez là c'est des mesures qui
flotte
on va voir un peu habile ya beaucoup
d'inconnues autour de ça ne serait pas
un passeport vaccinale ensemble danger
mais j'ai mal compris mais moi je vous
répète que je suis pour et la profession
là j'ai vu notamment je pense qu'au
milieu de la culture
mais c'est de la restauration sont
favorables à ce que pourquoi pas bon 10
en fonction de la superficie
d'établissement ne peut pas accueillir
plus de x personnes faut réserver je
pouvais prendre restants ont pourri faut
réserver avant d'aller au café très bien
faisons ça conditionnons soyons
rigoureux qui est du contrôle quiconque
ne respecte pas ces consignes ce sera
rudement sanctionné établissements
fermés j'ai pas de problème avec ça mais
associant les professions notamment il
ya des gens intelligents ce milieu là et
je moi inquiétudes que je vois pointé
c'est une situation sociale terrible et
là on va vers des faillites on en
parlait ce qui m'inquiète d'autant plus
quand tu voit arriver des dossiers comme
la réforme nation sur ma joue alors
qu'il faut des tirs et tirer des leçons
de tout ça on veut durcir encore plus
des éléments de protection sociale qui
existait jusqu'à parler de cette réforme
tout à l'heure mais un dernier mot sur
cette crise sanitaire et la phrase de
gabriella talent hier qui évoque un
retour à une vie presque normale
en tout cas une vie plus normale dès la
mi-avril est ce que le gouvernement a
raison d'évoquer ce genre de perspective
mais il faut donner des horizons
maintenant le problème c'est qu'on nous
avait aussi évoqué que 1 avril on devait
trachée plus combien 13 millions de gens
vaccinés
c'est peut-être pas tout à fait ce
chiffre enfin on est nettement en
dessous depuis le début le gouvernement
fixe des choses au petit roquet qui
n'arrivent pas à atteindre alors le
problème là encore on va arrêter sur
cette séquence mais le problème c'est le
nombre n'y a pas un nombre suffisant de
vaccins alors que luna on nous a dit que
c'était sa stratégie pourquoi n'y a pas
de vaccin français pourquoi on vaccine
pas davantage pourquoi le vaccin n'est
pas en licence publique
voyez ce que je veux dire
sortie de deux logiques marchandes parce
que c'est ça aussi le problème
on pourrait imaginer d'ailleurs une
licence d'office une forme de
réquisition de la part du gouvernement
qui dit ya des vaccins qui existent
actuellement il n'y a pas de raison que
ce soit des 10 ans privées qui vont de
pair avec des productions
il va y avoir il va ya voir pourquoi ya
pas pourquoi les raisons ce pays la
france qui était celui qui
historiquement marché devant sur le
vaccin qui a des instituts pasteur
absolument de grande qualité
pour quelle raison on a pris du retard
pourquoi sanofi notre grand groupe
pharmaceutique français est tombé dans
des logiques d'argent à reverser 4
milliards d'euros de dividendes à ses
actionnaires
alors qu'il est passé de 11 centres de
recherche à trois centres de recherche
pourquoi on a laissé faire ça pourquoi
on a laissé faire ça pourquoi on a
considéré qu'il n'y avait pas de
problème il ya dernière dernièrement que
ces groupes fassent du profit on s'est
désarmé vis-à-vis de ça alors qu' on en
avait besoin moi par exemple il ya deux
jours j'ai été en bretagne visiter une
usine qui est une société coopérative de
fabrication de masques fort heureusement
depuis peu maintenant il ya vingt-cinq
entreprises françaises qui fabrique des
masques
il ya un an au début de la crise duclos
vide on en fabrique et aucune
mais là encore société coopérative c'est
en bretagne j'ai trouvé ça formidable
parce qu'il faut sortir tous à deux
logiques marchandes
on a un besoin d'intérêt général ça
c'est la leçon qu'il faut tirer faudrait
pas que le monde qui sut soit le même
que le monde avant il n'y a pas
seulement le problème du coc vidya ça a
servi de caisse de résonance d'une
société ou c des logiques marchandes y
compris sur le vaccin bon sens le vaccin
faut pas faire de pognon avec le vaccin
je le dit vulgairement
c'est quelque chose qui est un bien
élémentaire il faudrait le produire plus
largement on va avancer dans le reste de
l'actualité le reste de l'actualité
c'est cette riposte médiatique de
nicolas sarkozy hier une grande
interview dans le figaro le matin
l'invitée du 20 heures de tf1 le soir il
trouve que sa condamnation est une
injustice et il se dit victime de
harcèlement de la part de la justice
depuis dix ans qu'est ce que vous avez
pensé de son interview ses interviews il
se défend c'est normal c'est un
combattant il juge qu'il a à faire à des
condamnations qui sont injustes moi je
veux dire c'est un adversaire politique
nicolas sarkozy nous on a eu c'est pas
une question d'élégance politique on le
combat politiquement quand il est
empêtré dans ses histoires de justice on
en rajoute pas moi j'aime pas le côté
bien fait pour lui bon il des condamnés
actuellement il fait appel donc la
condamnation elle est aujourd'hui en
quelque sorte elle tombe et il va vous
dire qu'il va se défendre
il ya dans des choses qui peuvent être
graves effectivement il n'ya pas
seulement un ancien présent de la
république est condamné il ya vingt
avocats il ya un magistrat ça veut dire
beaucoup de choses il faut en tirer
beaucoup de chose sur quoi bas sur
l'entretien magistrat qui est condamné
ça veut dire qu'aussi voyez il ya eu le
débat à l'indépendance de la justice
comment nous ont parfois autant
critiquer la justice et je la critique
pas dans son ensemble mais on voit bien
que dans cette affaire il peut y avoir
des liens ça arrive parfois des liens
entre des politiques et des magistrats
pas totalement fou de l'imaginer vu
comme magistrat et est condamné mais
plus largement ce que j'ai envie de dire
c'est qu'il faut réfléchir et je
n'écarte pas du sujet nous quand on
porte une sixième république - de
pouvoir sur le président de la
république à savoir que aujourd'hui
concentre énormément de pouvoir et la
possibilité y compris de jouer sur des
nominations de magistrats tout ça amène
à ce que ça une possibilité de
corruptibilité là encore je porte aucune
accusation précise sur ce dossier mais
c'est ça auquel il faut réfléchir une
indépendance et éventuellement du
parquet plus plus forte
moi je suis pour des magistrats
spécialisés mais il faut aussi qu'ils
aient des moyens il ya combien 800 à
faire actuellement qui pourrait être
ouverte sur des questions financières et
il ya très peu de magistrats pour les
mener donc choisir dans cette affaire
lesquels on suit est un choix très
politique
voyez c'est tout ça qui est qui et là
dedans jean luc mélenchon a réagi sur
twitter à cette condamnation alors pour
lui emmanuel macron pardon est
débarrassé d'un sérieux rival dans la
course à l'elysée est ce que ce n'est
pas une forme de soutien déclaration je
crois pas enfin je dirais franchement
voyez comment s'est il faut et vous êtes
des gens affûté précis c'est tout n'est
pas binaire
quand on me dit on voit bien aujourd'hui
c'est quoi le constate dans les
plongeons et de dire la droite à un
problème de représentation politique
dans les champs ce qui vient monsieur
mâcon va être le candidat de la droite
et dire on va en parler ça pose un
problème parce qu'il doit être celui qui
est le candidat qui englobe centre-droit
à droite en quelque sorte est le seul
candidat en capacité de battre dit-il
madame le pen sauf conservation qui est
aujourd'hui celui sans doute qui subit
quitte non mais c'est un tournant donc
nicolas sarkozy il ya même un
sous-entendu politique lequel il ya
quand même bien entendu que la politique
dans la décision de justice lui que
c'est un sacré client qui était encore
très haut dans
l'opinion de droite et qui de fait s'il
est empêché de voir la cette élection il
y en a quand même quelqu'un qui peut en
tirer un avantage dans une stratégie qui
explique qu'ils sont en train d'être
construite c'est le président actuel de
la république
une fois qu'on a dit ça on a des pubs
pas plus mais ça veut dire beaucoup donc
il ya une conséquence politique à cette
décision de justice voilà ce qu'il dit
après chacun en tire des conclusions et
va pas dire que c'est une décision
politique
cette décision ça veut pas dire ça
nécessairement mais ça veut dire que ça
a des conséquences politiques et naïf
celui qui ne les voient pas c'est naïf
celui qui croit d'ailleurs si on en
parle c'est pas parce que monsieur
sarkozy est entré seulement en retraite
c'est que c'est un acteur politique
encore bon il était candidat lors de la
dernière primaire de la droite et tout
le monde a bien compris que il pouvait
revenir dans le jeu peut-être d'ailleurs
qu'il va revenir dans le jeu on l'a vu
hier soir dans un état de fonctionnement
qui a l'air d'être assez opérationnelle
du point de vue mais moi je suis pas
sarkozyste à ces jeux du rejet le combat
politiquement mais nous le style kona
les insoumis même si un peu quand la
justice passe voilà c'est une chose
je fais une parenthèse au passage moi je
suis choqué par la justice qui cia 800
gilet jaune qui ont été condamnés par la
justice sans commentaire attend bien une
chose qui m'a choqué monsieur darmana
ministre de l'intérieur qui réaffirme
son affection et son soutien à nicolas
sarkozy
d'un certain point de vue ça a du
panache quand on est des copains
politiques mais comptez mise de
l'intérieur faudrait peut-être éviter ce
genre de commentaire ok bah que quand
voilà je veux dire quand ya 800 si
j'étais ministre de l'intérieur je
n'aurais pas fait ce genre de
commentaire voilà et ça donne quand même
l'impression qu'il ya un caractère un
peu exceptionnel à la situation de ce
sarkozy dans certains points c'est une
réalité il a été pris en la république
mais moi ce qui m'intéresse ou ce qui
m'indigne plus parfois c'est une justice
qui est dur avec les petites gens 800 j
les jeunes condamnés par la justice dont
certains pour la prison ferme ça ça me
choque ça ça me choque les geipan devenu
monsieur darmanin donné son affection
pour des pauvres gens bien sûr on qui
manifestaient pour que les minimas
sociaux soit relevé ce qui m'a l'air
d'être voilà même m'inquiète plus dans
ce pays
une fois qu'on a dit ça c'est maintenant
l'avenir qu'il faut construire un autre
sujet d'actualité avec ses corbières
c'est le sénat qui examine qui examine
en ce moment même la proposition de la
sécurité globale et le sénat veut
réécrire totalement l'article 24 plus de
référence à la diffusion d'image plus de
référence à la loi de 1881 sur la
liberté de la presse le sénat veut créer
un nouveau délit dans le code pénal le
délit de provocation à l'identification
des forces de l'ordre est-ce que vous
approuvez cette règle non non juste un
mot il ya vu le sénateur sueur il a dit
des choses claires retrait de cet
article 24 de toute manière la nouvelle
rédaction vous évoquez posera le même
problème c'est votre profession que je
défends parce qu'il n'ya pas de
démocratie possible sans liberté de la
presse et que vous le vouliez ou non
quels que soient les formulations qu'on
trouvera s'il s'agit de réduire la
possibilité éventuellement de filmer des
forces de l'ordre dans l'exercice de la
fin des 10 et répétée mois la
formulation un dédit à la provocation à
l'identification d'accord quant au nez
moi je suis des données personnelles
mais ça c'est déjà un possible par la
loi d'ores et déjà si je dis monsieur
machin fonctions de police habite à tel
endroit
c'est déjà condamnable et la personne
qui fait ça peut d'ores et déjà être
poursuivi maintenant il ya une chose et
je le dis compris aux fonctionnaires de
police qui font un métier indispensable
que je salue notamment ceux qui
travaillent dans ma circonscription mois
le commissaire du teddy da et un homme
avec lequel du club de la ville des dix
là où il ya mon commissariat qui m'a
vide est un homme qui travaille en lien
avec les élus et je salue le travail
difficile qu'ils ont mais moi je suis
enseignante comme quand je suis pas
député on a le droit de critiquer les
enseignants on a le droit aussi de
critiquer la police sans pour autant
considérer que toute entière ou je ne
sais trop quoi mais d'observer qui a
parfois des pratiques qui sont kiss qui
sont critiquables cas des conditions
travail qui leur sont critiquables et
tout est dans les manifestations on a vu
dernièrement mais c'était sont des
consignes qui était donnée qui avait des
choses
j'évoquais tout à l'heure les gilet
jaune tout neuf le nombre de gens
blessés dans ces manifestations
moi j'ai une certaine expérience des
manifestations j'ai jamais vu autant de
décès on a le droit de critiquer ça donc
voyez le problème c'est que si on va
faire des images après on va dire oui
mais on peut reconnaître la personne et
c'est bon on va nécessairement réduire
la possibilité pour le citoyen d'avoir
un regard sur le travail qui est fait en
son nom sur un sondage sur la laïcité
française
le sondage sur la laïcité française oui
ifop
donc voilà ce ce sondage démontre que la
laïcité à la française est rejetée par
une majorité de lycéens 52 % se disent
favorables au port de signes religieux
ostensibles dans les établissements 38%
une loi autorisant le port du burkini
est ce que cette fracture
générationnelle vous inquiète alors
première mon port du burkini ça c'est
pas la laïcité ça notre débat je vois
pas ce que ça vient faire dans la
discussion parce que la loi de 1905
pourrait très bien permettre qu'on aille
à la plage avec la tenue qu'on veut
quelque chose qu'on en pense dit pas que
j'approuve
mais voyez le problème quand vous avez
38 % des lycéens qui se disent
favorables à une loi autorisant un
burqini ça vous inquiète ou pas mais
c'est un débat qui n'a rien à voir avec
la laïcité juston je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les débats sont mal posé
moi je pense que le mot de laïcité que
tout le monde utilise de l'extrême
droite à ce gouvernement pour lui faire
dire autre chose
autre chose amen à ce que c'est un mot
devenu extrêmement confus et les gens
ont l'impression que c'est un terme
utilisé terme magnifique le l'idéal
d'émancipation que je défends pour cible
et unique ont une partie de nos
concitoyens qui notamment ceux de
confession musulmane qui serait
prétendument les seuls à poser problème
sur la laïcité
à l'occasion du débat qui vient d'avoir
lieu sur le loi de renforcer les
principes républicains
j'ai posé le problème que dans 10 pays
il ya trois départements 3 3 millions de
nos concitoyens haut rhin bas rhin et
moselle qui vivent dans des départements
où la loi de 1905 ne s'applique pas où
il ya un financement public des
religions potes tout d'ailleurs pas
celle de confession musulmane
ça coûte 62 millions d'euros d'argent
public chaque année pour financer les
ministres du culte de deux trois
religions mais pas quatre bons et suite
à sa date ya plus d'un siècle en raison
de l'histoire ou qu'on connaît ce pays
pourquoi n'applique pas la laïcité sur
tout le territoire langue dira mais non
ça il faut pas bon moi je considère que
je suis laïc pour tous les français
égalité devant la loi
là par contre pas ce débat par contre on
va embêter tout une série de nos
concitoyens en sous-entendant que le
problème c'est dans les mosquées et en
faisant une loi de suspicion généralisée
que je n'ai pas soutenu qui ne règle
absolument rien des problèmes que nous
avons eus du terrorisme donc les les
gamins
envie de dire et moi je vous savez j'ai
trois enfants deux filles notamment qui
sont aujourd'hui 10 n étudiante
effectivement il voit tout ça donne à
ils ont une solidarité vis-à-vis de
leurs camarades
quelle que soit leur confession
religieuse qui parfois moi j'ai des
désaccords avec cette jeunesse mais qui
dit nous toucher panneau quand il y en a
ras-le-bol et c'est pas parce que
djamila ou david porte une kippa ou
djamila porte le foulard qui pose
problème alors je dis pas qu'ils ont
toujours raison mais il ya dans tout ça
à la fois quelque chose qui peuvent
inquiéter parce que je regrette qu'ils
ne comprennent pas la laïcité mais que
je vois parfois donner aussi sympathique
que yann jeunesse quand même qui reste
assez anti racistes assez à l'idée que
ils veulent pas que certains de nos
concitoyens sont montrés du doigt donc
quelle conclusion je conclus on doit on
doit en tirer c'est re définir ce qu'est
la laïcité c'est la loi 1905 ses deux
premiers articles pas financement public
du culte c'est pourquoi le concordat
d'alsace-moselle me pose problème et
liberté de conscience c'est pourquoi en
droit de critiquer les religions mon
endroit aussi pratiquer sa religion et
il faut arrêter de casser les pieds
après aux citoyens s'ils respectent la
loi sur leurs convictions spirituelles
we are évoquant cette réforme qui
revient sur la table devrait entrer en
vigueur au 1er juillet est ce que le
gouvernement a raison de justement de la
remettre sur la table en pleine période
de crise sanitaire voilà même si le le
calendrier pourrait coïncider avec un
début de sortie de crise un passé du
moins ce qu'espère le gouvernement
évidemment non il a tort de remettre
cela sur la table et c'est même honteux
d'un point de vue économique d'un point
de vue social non point de vue politique
ce dont on parle c'est le fait qu'il va
y avoir 40 % de ceux qui aujourd'hui
dispose d'une bonne assurance chômage
qui vont voir leurs droits réduits
je rappelle qu'un chômeur sur deux ne
perçoit rien d'ores et déjà à l'heure
actuelle le nombre de chômeurs va
augmenter à on va passer sans doute de
700 à 800 mille chômeurs supplémentaires
et quelle conclusion en tire le
gouvernant qui soit disant nous disait à
n'importe quel prix on va affronter à la
clé du coffre vide etc
c'est de baisser les indemnités pour
pour les chemins qu'est ce qu'on va y
gagner absolument rien on va faire
tomber des gens dans la pauvreté
je rappelle qu'au delà du caractère
indigne que vous et moi on a tous eu à
vis de la pauvreté
si combien ça coûte cher la pauvreté
parce que ça amène beaucoup de
concéquence par la suite des gens qui
sont que kiki qui craque littéralement
sans compter que le nombre de on est
abîmée de par sa santé je le mets de
côté y compris les suicides que ça peut
entraîner et c'est donc on n'a aucun
intérêt à ça alors qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire il faut défendre bien entendu
notre système d'assurance chômage je
rappelle qu il y avait le plein emploi
la soupe d huile et dans les années 70
l'assurance chômage était au plus haut
niveau donc il n'y a pas de corrélation
entre les deux et après il faut aller
vers le plein emploi c'est ce qu'on
défend avec jean luc mélenchon c'est à
dire réduire le temps de travail
pourquoi pas passer vers les 32 heures
35 heures effectives même 32 heures
sixième semaine de congés payés etc
aller vers le fait qu' il est bon que
tout le monde travaille et alexis
corbière nous reste malheureusement à
redon temps mais il faudrait qu'on parle
des régionales comme avant de se quitter
régionales en île de france et un
sondage ifop qui est paru avant-hier qui
donne valérie pécresse largement devant
tous ses adversaires et notamment les
trois listes de gauche qui sont autour
de 10 % 10 % notamment pour clémentine
autain est-ce que c'est pas la preuve
que les divisions de la gauche sont en
train d'ouvrir un boulevard à vallet
être d'offrir un boulevard à valérie
pécresse dombasle la droite était assez
forte en ile de france dans une élection
souvent qui est caractérisée par
l'abstention c'est d'ailleurs le
problème ce que disent pas à cesser ces
sondages une abstention qui en plus
profitent bien souvent aux départements
les plus à droite ça c'est scandaleux
parce que j'ai pas le temps de
développer mais les départements
populaires comme la seine-saint-denis
quand ya moins de participation ils ont
moins d'élus que ceux de droite ne vous
à une sur-représentation après wurz et
régionale ile de france de la droite qui
qui qui est assez problématique moi je
serais pour que l'on change ça
deuxièmement nous on a fait notamment en
direction d'europe écologie les verts
des propositions d'actions communes
europe ecologie les verts ne conçoit les
choses que derrière eux à l'heure
actuelle enfin je voudrais juste ira
peut-être après un second tour qui peut
avoir lieu
à l'heure actuelle il faut faire
entendre des propositions fortes c'est
ce que nous disons l'île de france doit
pas être au service uniquement de
descartes des départements les plus
fortunés il faut notamment que la
seine-saint-denis le val-de-marne et des
cadres des départements populaire se
fassent entendre
clémentine autain porte ça et dans le
beaucoup de départements on est engagé
et on peut marcher en tête pourquoi pas
et ça facilitera le rassemblement de
beaucoup d'électeurs sur tout ce qu'il
faut arriver à faire c'est une valise de
gauche d'un sondage vous êtes la
troisième oui mais peu
à peu de choses près on est sans ciment
par an près on va voir de quelle manière
non mais il y avait par contre une forme
d'arrogance ya quelques temps de
considérer que c'était une icône
derrière les encours devaient se
rassembler c'est plus compliqué que ça
donc chacun de toi peut-être en tire des
conclusions y compris pour l'élection
présidentielle
la question c'est metz on a quand même
le sentiment que voilà sans fusion au
second tour point de salut pour pour la
gauche face à valérie pécresse
mais il y aura peut-être une fusion
second tour ce que je souhaite déjà il
ya une campagne qui doit avoir lieu
de toute façon et il s'agit pas de
considérer que les sondages règle la
faire bon moi ce qui m'intéresse surtout
c'est l'élection présidentielle qui va
suivre
il ya une campagne à mener sur la base
d'idées claires 1 c'est ça qui me semble
important la campagne nous sommes pour
être jean-luc mélenchon et c'est une
campagne qui danger la cohérence d'un
programme et ceux qui veulent se
rassembler j'entends des voix mais
pourquoi pas mais je veux dire on peut
aussi nous créer des conditions de ce
rassemblement
ouais il faut pas non plus il ya des
gens qui exclut les insoumis a priori on
est serait là uniquement pour apporter
notre soutien et nous voit et nous taire
non non je pense que nous sommes aux
jaune et la force qui la première
opposition à ce gouvernement qui a
aujourd'hui un candidat je parle
d'élection présidentielle jean luc
mélenchon qui est connue reconnue on a
un groupe parlementaire qui fait du
boulot et on peut créer les conditions
de ce rassemblement
si tout le monde vivait de la bonne foi
et merci beaucoup merci avec ses cordes
et à bientôt merci d'être venu nous voir
on regarde la une de l'écho républicain
c'est pas de sens et la télémédecine qui
fait des émules merci beaucoup et ses
malheurs on passe au club de taito la
mutuelle nationale territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux vous présente le club des
territoires angie acteurs engagés
n'aurait transition zéro carbone des
régions vous présente le club des
territoires
[Musique]